Man's best friend with benefits.
These are Dogs for Diabetics.
They're trained to smell dangerous changes in blood sugar levels...
...then alert their owners.
It cost around $50,000 for the organization to train each dog...
...but for diabetics who qualify, the dogs are free.
Mark Ruefenacht is the founder of Dogs for Diabetics.
He's a diabetic who loves to gather data.
So Ruefenacht demonstrates how his diabetes dogs smell low blood sugar...
...by using jars containing swabs of sweat from a diabetic...
...who did have low blood sugar.
Ruefenacht's sweat jar method for training his diabetes alert dogs...
...has been validated scientifically.
This is how  they let him know that his blood sugar level is dropping...
...but because the monitor shows his blood sugar was normal...
...just a few minutes earlier,...
...Ruefenacht decides the dogs simply want to play.